we solicited a bunch of questions from
fans for you so this is these are all
coming from the fame I love it
David D'Arcy wants to know what will you
miss most about playing Wolverine I love
this character I genuinely love it I
love the fanbase although I'm going be
living them because I know for 17 years
they've stopped me every day in the
street but it may be hard for me to
watch whoever plays it next because I do
love that character I wish I was a
little more like him in some ways you
know what's interesting Gavin R wants to
know if you had the chance to become
Wolverine for real no no now he's
tortured
he's quite a tortured character and it
was really interesting trying to play it
in a real way because there are a lot of
people doing that kind of stuff doing
some pretty dark stuff for good reasons
and there is a cost of that life there's
no joke and it's tough for all of us and
you have to find a way through that to
find some peace yoga who Gucci wants to
know what was that last day on set like
for you when you had to put down the
claws for the last time what were you
feeling it was calm actually relatively
calm people say is that like you know
you won the Super Bowl the end I'm like
no is this a run was like I've gotta go
we're gonna catch some flights and we're
off and I had a series of dinners in
that last month
we're there almost everybody in the crew
and that was really great so by the time
we left it was sort of like it's time to
go home yeah Charles in this film he's
weak he's unexpectedly powerful he's
funny he's foul mouth is this your
favorite version of the character you've
played well I feel bad for him yeah he's
in trouble and I always liked the guy he
was before compassionate caring
sensitive intelligence saving the world
these are all qualities that you can
respect and Lord knows I wish we had a
few of them around right now but there
is a real fascination in saying what if
actually he could be the deadliest
person on the planet in some ways it's
about the power of comic books curious
isn't that a great meta I'm glad you
picked that up
did you read comics growing up I'm
curious about your powerful nose Barry
with the comic-book woods no I've never
read a comic book in my life really
never read a comic book before I just
didn't have access to them when I was a
kid but I was so attracted to the
scripts what was your most powerful
experience with a comic book more than
movies more than anything else there
were very sophisticated stories and you
felt like you were getting inside the
emotional lives of these characters one
of the things that have been missed most
often as comic books are converted into
movies is that they tend to get more
childish as they become movies then stay
as kind of witty and edgy and
sophisticated as they were as comic
books even when we started writing this
even when I asked Jim mango to come
aboard I said dude I don't know if I'm
gonna make it because unless it's
exactly where I want I prefer to not do
it I couldn't live with it myself so
this was this is it you still have time
[Music]
you